first of all it's Kitty I want to
congratulate you on your third movie
YouTube update I know you've been
adapting this since 2016. how does it
feel to have it finally release
I mean it feels incredible and um there
have been so many people that have
helped me with this in the last couple
of years
um just with a different uh drafts and
um we did like a short film a couple of
years ago to try to get financing and
um so it's it's been quite a journey and
it's it's really exciting to
put it out into the world and and
um I hope that audiences like it we
worked really hard
well I liked it it's a really it's a
really cute great film it really shows
like the power female friendship so I
was curious what's for both of you guys
what female friendship like really
encouraged encourages you throughout
your life
well I mean I think the amount female
friendship is is very important
um and I for me showing that on film was
important to me like this isn't Thelma
and Louise but I love the Friendship of
those two women I love seeing
feet like women on screen together
supporting each other
um and so that was really
very
um
inspiring for me to do
and I depend on my female friends to you
know help me in my ups and downs so it
felt authentic to me
I'm going to agree with that one of
course my
um as I said before like I I wouldn't be
here without my girlfriends and my
sisters I they're
um they're so important in my life we
get to experience it it doesn't
necessarily have to mean like I only go
to them for advice even just the
presence even just being there and I
think sometimes you see that in Benita
and Diana that you're
um you don't necessarily have to have a
therapy session or anything but like you
know the presence of someone being there
to get you out of your head or to
experience life and sometimes it is
supportive like emotionally
um but it can be in so many ways whether
you're dancing whether you're you know
get uh drinking whether you're or having
a heart-to-heart conversation if there's
so many different ways where that's
where it's valued and beautiful no I
totally understand that I'm like that
with my sister so I totally connect with
that also with connection like this
movie is a lot about objects having
meaning or maybe even luck do you guys
have like objects that like gives you
luck or has a value a meaning to you
I mean yes I I mean I love going to flea
markets and I love
finding different things
um
so I um
yeah I mean it's just like
things like my grandmothers gave me
those have a lot of meaning to me
yeah
um I carry around anywhere I go like a
photograph of
um it's me my sister and my mom like
when I was like probably four and I
think that's like the most I think
that's like the most value because I
lose everything I lose jewelry like
anything I'm just like it's all gone but
that I have it in a book and I'm just
like that's my most prized I think
possession
something similar to that so I totally
understand and also Julie I have to ask
how is it working with Katie being
directed Katie you wrote this directed
so how is it working being alongside
with her like being the star of the
movie
um it's inspiring to watch someone do
everything you know it's some and make
it seem so easy it's it's but I could
not have done it without Julia she very
much helped me write it
oh very much brought so much to this
character and she's a movie star she
Sparkles she's got so much joy and does
really light up these scenes and the
movie
if if we didn't have Benita it would not
have worked so I depended on her so much
she really brought
my vision to life and I you know her
Talent her work ethic was
really incredible so I'm I owe a lot to
Julia for sure but I mean also when
you're doing something like this I think
you need you need to rely a lot you know
you need to trust that somebody has a
vision and even though you come in with
ideas and I think Katie does an amazing
job she knows what she wants she gets in
there and she's like also has enough
space to play like you know she might
come in with ideas but
um once she sees something she also gets
inspired in the moment so I think
there's a lot of fluidity that's
happening on set so it's you know you're
on your toes but that's a good thing
because that's where the magic happens
first off I want to ask Alan in your own
words what is this film about
uh this film is about
people who are broken who find each
other and and ultimately it's about the
idea that being broken can make you more
beautiful and more whole actually and
that we're all a bit broken
um and um that's not necessarily the end
of your story if you're if you have been
broken
I love that yes and a lot with the
broken objects obviously there's a lot
of connection to objects I was curious
with both of you guys do you have like a
personal object that means a lot to you
yeah personally but I have a I have uh
This is Gonna sound so nuts but I have a
um a snow globe with Minnie Mouse in it
the water's evaporated now so it's a
little hard to shake her but what a time
in my life when I was so low and
desperate and just everything was going
wrong and I was really not not in a good
place a dear friend of mine took me to
Disneyland Paris and he said you're
going and we're gonna have fun and I
went there and I actually had joy for
the first time in in many many months
and I got this little things whenever I
looked at it it reminds me that even in
the darkest place you can find Joy so
that's my special brilliant object yeah
I love that
I don't know that I have a
hmm no when I think about object I think
about
space
you know I think about the
finding a a place to uh sort of uh reset
and to you know
just breathe again but I don't have one
particular object
um next time I see you I will
think about that one please
Derek this is your second movie working
with Katie so what would you want to
come back working with her well actually
this is my third
this is my second this is director as a
director
um I
like I enjoy
um Katie I enjoy her care
um and uh we were filming somewhere on a
previous film and like
I wasn't thinking about this but she
heard that I was walking somewhere
and I I wasn't too familiar with the
area so literally she came met me in a
hotel gave me her car keys and she's
like you're not walking from here to
there and here's my keys and you know
for the little time I've been doing this
uh that meant a lot that meant more than
you know the character it really spoke
to her character yeah so I I enjoyed
that Katie you know and creating and I'm
sorry yeah and I'm always telling her
like get ready
but the series movies things coming up
for you that you you need to continue
doing this yeah
no it's such a great film and Alan I
just want to ask you how I was working
with Katie because this is your first
film with her am I a corrected that yes
yes it's my first film with Kitty I've
known I'd known her over the years uh
but we just this was great to sort of
you know get to know her better and
become more friends and I really enjoyed
working on this film and actually we've
been working on another film writing
another film together and two of us
that's been really lovely and I think
she's great because you know you she's
this sort of
I think we all think we know a lot about
her in her life
um and but she's this beautiful woman
but she's also a bit of a geek and she's
incredibly kind and and loving and a
very sort of almost a sort of an Amazon
actually she seems this little could
seem like a little frail girl sometimes
but actually she's a strong woman she's
been through a lot and she's she's like
the film she has uh she has been broken
and she has put herself back together
and she is more strong and beautiful
because of it no I love that Alan so can
you tease us what you guys are working
on
it's a film again a little film about
you know where like this nothing it's
not people are talking people talking it
it's about family and it's sort of uh we
uh we're sort of step step siblings and
um set in New York wandering around New
York stuff you know
magic no car chases uh just sort of but
then but but a big shock at the end